they had something where they were on
your ass recently uh you would on Tick
Tock yeah was it like a Latin joke or
something I don't think I think I think
people took out of context that they
don't realize you're married to a Latin
woman yeah so that but it's interesting
so that happened you know the Mexican
Community was coming after me right and
I understood the wording of that joke
because basically what I was trying to
say was it's basically it was a whole
made-up scenario so what I was trying to
say was is that TT Jerry who if you
don't know she's on my podcast she's a
transgender Latina woman did 20 years in
prison you know Puerto Rican like she's
like you know it's it's it's my wife's
uncle and she's actually my kids
godmother now and you know whatever
she's my family and so so we you know
say wild [ __ ] on the Pod together but we
were saying that there was a guy was
fixing my uh a friend family friend was
fixing an air conditioner unit in my in
my uh attic and his foot went through
the ceiling right so I was like and he
said he was like he was like oh [ __ ] he
goes I'm sorry I was like yeah whatever
just passed ouch it up and then and then
he goes and then he goes he was like
he's Spanish but he was like oh I don't
have my papers I don't have my papers
and then like so we were just like
joking around like that and all laughing
so then I went to the podcast the next
day and that's what it is like you take
scenarios like that and you make bits
and you make yeah that's even on a
podcast people like hey what you said
about X Y and Z that you know sometimes
my family called me like that's not true
right I'm not this isn't therapy right
we're doing a show yeah so we're
entertaining people so what happened was
I said on the podcast I said oh you know
like a a Mexican uh worker fell through
my ceiling yesterday and I was like you
know I was like uh T you know he said
that his neck hurt and then TT Jerry
went up there and was like I said that
he fell through this what I meant to say
was he fell through the ceiling and then
20 minutes later all of a sudden he said
his neck hurt and then TT Jerry went up
the stairs like oh your neck hurt
where's your pay first and then he was
like I don't have papers and he was like
trabajo like that so but the way the
tick tock came out was I didn't say the
20 minute part and I just didn't work it
right so it sounded like especially if
you don't know me sounds like this white
guy is here talking about the Latino
community and and all the and it got to
the point where like people are like
somebody goes we found the worker we're
gonna we're gonna leave we found them
some later some like famous
Mexican-American attorney or I guess
famous on Tick Tock was like We messaged
me they're like we found the worker we
are going to represent him for free or
ask his grants I was like the worker is
literally a dummy from Staten Island
who's a family friend like what there's
you know you didn't find there's no
worker so I texted his name is Anthony I
was like did anybody reach out to he was
like I don't even have a cell phone like
you know like so like it's just like
stupid and then these people attack so
but then it's interesting because it's
just a microcosm like social media it's
just a microcosm people because you
think they're like oh people are like
sending me like death threats right and
then I did shows coincidentally I think
three weeks later in um in the not the
Irvine uh was yeah it was the Irvine
Improv which is a huge Mexican of course
community in North Korea bro the produce
sir I'm sorry the manager of the club
you know is beautiful sold out shows
thank you to people of Irvine of course
you know it's like all the shows put
together it's like 3 000 tickets so it's
like a big ass venue six six six shows
500 people each show he told me he was
like other than Felipe Esparza who's a
huge Mexican L.A because you have the
most Mexican fans I've ever seen in this
venue and all of them love none of them
even none of them even saw that Tick
Tock there was barely any of them did
and the ones that did were like like yo
it was [ __ ] hilarious let's think
about the internet it's like you can't
take it too serious because it's always
the really loud minority and like you
always think in your head everybody saw
this when you know really not that many
people in your real life for fans really
actually give a [ __ ] or yeah because you
have to also understand you have to
understand the mindset of someone on
social media for you to even
both ways and listen it's all good I I
you know will appreciate it like
whatever but for you to comment
negatively on someone's Instagram or
Tick Tock publicly or positively it's a
little bit like most people don't give a
[ __ ] at all right most people are like
yeah I just move on with my [ __ ] like I
would comment on something you because
we know each other but for random people
to comment or send you DMS positive or
negative is a little like it's just
strange and most most people most people
don't care most people didn't even see
that Tick Tock or they did they didn't
give a [ __ ] and they bought a ticket
because they like me from other things
or they didn't buy tickets because they
don't like me forever so the people that
get so wrapped up so actually a step
that I've taken is and I understand you
know not everyone can do this I get it
to be in a fortunate position but I have
now given the keys to my all my social
media Instagram Tick Tock Twitter
everything to someone else to a a guy
who works for my management company I
know him very well he has the passwords
to everything I purposely don't told him
do not give I don't want to know I don't
want to have access into my own social
media you you know if somebody like you
reached out and he was like yo and then
he'll send it to me about give him my
number tell him to text me we'll do
things like that but I'm like I don't
want to know because it is a thing a lot
of people talk about
negative comments and how it messes with
your brain chemistry 100 accurate so do
positive ones positive ones take you out
into these egotistical state where you
aren't who you really are so I said you
know what I don't need it anymore it's
built up to me where it's comfortable
like you know whatever I however many
you know hundreds of thousands are on
there it's comfortable enough for me
it's a ticket selling apparatus for me I
I tell my guy what to post every day
give him the video tell him the caption
so it is my writing and my work of
course but I don't have any I don't know
who's saying who's DM who's commenting
even after shows there would be a thing
where I'd be paralyzed after shows you
you have a good show 30 50 100 DMS girls
guys I want to hang out I want to take
you to bar and I'd be oh my God you
almost have some you know sometimes too
many options too much choice is not
Freedom if you're in prison with too
many choices that's that's a thing where
it's like I I felt like the less I had
the less people that have access to me
the Freer I am so I was like now the
only people that have access to me is if
you have my number or my email if you're
a personal friend or family member then
we can talk other than that there's a
layer there's someone a buffer in front
and bro it's made everything in my life
so much better from from from
relationship with my girl relationship
with my kids my body I've lost like 25
pounds fasting working out because I'm
not I'm not sucked in you're not stuck
on the phone I'm not sucked into the
toxicity of it even you know yes yes
women you know all that stuff you know
because sex is an addiction like
anything else that gets you in trouble
of course uh comparison you know my one
of my favorite quotes I just did a video
about it from Teddy Roosevelt who says
oh my fault these guys crying uh one one
of my favorite quotes from Teddy
Roosevelt is um is a comparison is the
thief of Joy oh yeah it's the worst yeah
so so I don't compare myself to my peers
I don't know what my peers are doing I'm
happy for whatever they're doing I only
I compare me to me even on social media
somet times you compare you to you and
that's not good either you'll look at a
picture or video of yourself from 10
months ago and be like why don't why
don't I look like that anymore or I was
more popping back then it's all [ __ ]
yeah so I just stay for me I've made a
decision I only care I also don't want
someone on the other side of the world
to
influence my day I don't they don't know
me I don't know them so I made another
choice where I was like I'm only going
to deal with the opinions of the people
in the room with me or my friends and
family those people I would care about
if I'm being a physical person but some
other person writing something on
YouTube or Instagram I don't give it I
don't give it my head space anymore some
people are strong enough to say well I
just won't look I wasn't I had to just
look myself in the mirror and say you're
you're too much of a of a [ __ ] Chris
right you need to get rid of it so I did
just I didn't delete it because I you
know again it's a ticket selling out
there it's part of your but I don't have
any access to it so like if you DM
people in my life who you know
communicating with who do have my number
like yo are you mad at me you don't
respond to my DMs anymore I'm like bro
you got to text me I don't have any
information I don't I don't even have a
way into that anymore and um you know I
know that you know that not everybody
has to do that but for me I've only seen
positive change uh since I've gotten
less like Less on social media and more
just focusing on on the people in front
of me